[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 12 avril voici
les titres
elle a été lancée ce matin voisins le
bretonneux déploie sa vie s'ils
n'avaient un mini bus à destination des
seniors le véhicule circulera les mardis
et jeudis matins pour desservir 13
arrêts de la ville une première phase de
test se déroule jusqu'à cet été en vue
du deuxième tour de la présidentielle
beaucoup d'électeurs sont dans le flou
pour qui voter emmanuel macron marine le
pen ou bien s'abstenir pour dépasser
cette angoisse électorale et conseils
dans cette édition de catherine grand
jard psychanalyste installées à ben et
puis retour sur le concert pour
l'ukraine il s'est tenue en fin de
semaine dernière à la chapelle royale du
château de versailles un événement à
l'initiative du département des yvelines
qui a permis de récolter 40 2900 euros
nous recevrons également tout à l'heure
zachary hardy président du medef des
yvelines l'organisation patronale qui a
appelé à voter pour emmanuel macron en
vue du deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle
[Musique]
ce matin c'était donc l'inauguration
pour la vie si navette ce minibus de six
places réservées aux seniors circulera
les mardis et jeudis matin à voisins le
bretonneux cette navette desservira très
arrête dans différents quartiers les
précisions de céline charme c'était une
promesse de campagne voisins le
bretonneux a mis en circulation ce mardi
12 avril sa vie si navette un minibus
pour les seniors l'idée de la vessie
navette est née de la questionnaire
qu'on avait fait il ya deux ou trois ans
auprès des seniors et puis de l'analyse
des besoins sociaux qu'on est en train
de terminer qui montrait que beaucoup de
gens restés un peu isolé parce que
déplacements intra muros dans la commune
était un petit peu complexe la navette
desservira très rares et les mardis et
les jeudis matins dans des points
stratégiques de la ville deux allers
retours sont prévus par matinée là par
exemple on est dans le centre commercial
de la grande île mais l'arrêt suivant
c'est le centre commercial de la
bretonnière pour avant d'arriver au
centre commercial du centre-ville vous
avez la poste la mairie
centre culturel decauville vous
l'apprendrez puisse arrêter quelque part
est allé faire une promenade à pied à
l'autre bout de la commune je pense par
exemple à la croix du bois une façon
pour la commune de lutter contre l'
isolement chez les plus âgés on sait
qu'il ya des gens isolés de parts soit
parce qu'ils connaissent pas grand monde
soit parce que ils n'ont pas de moyen de
déplacement la façon dont la ville est
faite fait que les gens vivent beaucoup
au fait recentrer sur leur quartier et
c'est aussi l'occasion pour des vies si
noah qui le souhaitent pas de connaître
un petit peu mieux leur commune en se
promenant de quartier en quartier pour
l'instant le minibus n'en est qu'à son
stade d'essai les horaires et le trajet
vont être adaptés en fonction des
retours des utilisateurs pour bénéficier
de la navette il suffit de se rendre sur
l'un des arrêts desservis le service est
pour l'instant gratuit jusqu'à fin juin
dans l'actualité également les résultats
de l'élection municipale de tra bien
confirmée par le tribunal administratif
de versailles l instance a rejeté le
recours qui contestaient l'issue de ce
scrutin partiel organisé en octobre 2021
est remporté par rallye rabais dès le
premier tour à la tête de la liste la
gauche unie pour que tu rappes respire
recours déposé par othman nasri
candidats battus et principal opposant
de droite au conseil municipal qui
dénonçait des irrégularités il est donc
débouté pour rappel la municipale
partielle avait dû se tenir l'an passé
après l'annulation de l'élection de 2020
remporté par ali rabais et dont les
comptes de campagne avaient été
invalidées et dans moins de deux
semaines c'est une autre élection qui va
se jouer la présidentielle le 24 avril
les électeurs devront trancher entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen avec la
crise sanitaire et la guerre en ukraine
il peut s'installer une forme d'anxiété
politique quelles sont les causes les
manifestations et que faut-il faire pour
la contrer les conseils de catherine
granja psychosociologue installées à ben
ali a été interrogé par bixente n'a rien
senti steban et céline charles
voter est un acte si simple d'apparence
qui peut devenir un poids une pression
voire une angoisse d'abord qui choisir
puis ai je fait le bon choix et lorsque
les résultats paraissent parfois la
déception un phénomène étudié par la
psychosociologue catherine grand jard il
ya des gens qui pleurent kepler
littéralement le soir des résultats il
ya des gens qui éclate en sanglots qui
sont inconsolables parce que quelque
chose disparaît un premier tour
comparable un chagrin d'amour un espoir
perdu qu'il faut pourtant surmonter en
l'espace de deux semaines avant le
second vote nous allons faire le deuil
d'un idéal et une fois ce deuil de
l'idéal fait il y a la rencontre avec la
réalité et la réalité c'est que nous ne
sommes pas dans la puissance outre le
temps qui atténue les émotions certaines
clés existent pour passer à autre chose
la prise de conscience que 1 votée n'est
pas aimé c'est un choix qui va permettre
de s'éloigner le moins possible de ces
valeurs même si on sait bien que c'est
un second choix et par aussi
enthousiasmant que le premier mais aussi
il n'ya pas que le vol puisque d'autres
formes d'engagement existe des
engagements comme le mouvement
associatif ou encore se lancer dans la
perspective des prochaines élections les
législatives et même plus simplement
faire une action en faveur de ses
valeurs peut-être la petite action pour
certains ça va être de planter un arbre
ou bien de il ya la guerre en ukraine de
s'engager pour l'accueil
des personnes qui arrivent en attendant
il reste moins de quinze jours pour
surpasser cette angoisse l'angoissent
d'un jour où tout le monde est à égalité
ou un vote est égal au vote d'à côté
il appelle à voter pour emmanuel macron
le medef s'est exprimé sur le sujet ce
lundi dans un communiqué l'organisation
patronale juge le programme du président
sortant plus favorable pour assurer la
croissance de l'économie et de l'emploi
fin de citation par rapport à celui de
marine le pen pour parler d'eux ce
communiqué de cette prise de position
aux acariens hardy est avec mon plateau
bonsoir bonsoir êtes de président du
medef dans les yvelines prise de
position on peut lire sans surprise mes
prises de position quand même quand
d'autres organisations comme la ceppm
élus de paix ont choisi de ne pas donner
de consigne de vote pourquoi sortir de
cette neutralité pour le medef côté le
medef et le parti de l'entreprise et
nous appartiennent pas de appelé à voter
pour un candidat ou pour un autre
cependant il est je dirais dans notre
pouvoir de parler des programmes et
d'évaluer leur impact économique et
social
nous le medef nous sommes favorables à
un monde ouvert libre et stable pour
favoriser la prospérité économique
cependant c'est vrai quand on compare
les programmes de emmanuel macron et le
programme de marine le pen nous
constatons quand même que certaines
dispositions qui sont dans le programme
de marine le pen ne sont pas finançable
elles seront financées certainement par
la dette ou l'impôt et ce sont deux
choses qui sont préjudiciables pour
l'économie en france dans un instant
alors d'après les informations du
journal les échos toutes les fédérations
du medef n'était pas forcément d'accord
pour une prise de position sur le sujet
des présidentielles c'est dire qu'il ya
des divergences entre les chefs
d'entreprise sur sur ce sujet n'ont pas
tout à fait disons que nous on travaille
avec tout le monde on travaille avec la
gauche à droite le centre c'est notre
adn et c'est comme ça que que nous
voyons si vous voulez nos relations avec
les politiques cependant c'est vrai il
peut y avoir des divergences par rapport
à certaines prises de position mais
néanmoins on a préféré si vous voulez
prendre position par rapport à des
programmes et leurs impacts économiques
et c'était ça si vous voulez notre
démarche aujourd'hui avec ses prises de
positions n'y at il pas un risque de
renforcer le clivage entre les élites le
peuple peut-être aussi renforcer cette
image de président des riches que cas
emmanuel macron
non disons que nous essayons d'être
sensible à la partie économique des
programmes nous souhaitons rester
vraiment autour de cela et encore une
fois je dis que le medef c'est le parti
de l'entreprise et il nous appartient
pas effectivement de se taire un
candidat par rapport à un autre mais
surtout qu'on évalue le programme des
uns et des autres et nous sommes assez
attentifs à l'impact que certaines
décisions vont prendre la situation est
très difficile
la france est très endetté
nous voulons vraiment aller vers une
présidence une une un quinquennat qui va
être fait d' expertise d'expérience de
savoir faire et nous pensons que
effectivement le programme de du manuel
macro va être favorable aux entreprises
beaucoup plus que celui de marine le pen
face à celui de marine le pen qui je
cite selon le medef conduirait le pays a
décroché par rapport à ses voisins et à
le mettre en marge de l'union européenne
or pour préciser quelques points du
programme économique de marine le pen
qui souhaitent un maintien de la
retraite à 62 ans et ré indexer les
pensions de retraite retraite sur sur
l'inflation une baisse de la tva aussi
de 20 % à 5 5 % sur les énergies un
impôt sur la fortune financière on peut
citer également une aide pour les chefs
d'entreprise pour augmenter de 10% leurs
salariés qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète
vous le disiez tout à l'heure c'est un
programme financé par la dette c'est ça
qui vous inquiète le plus dans ce
programme de tels de telles décisions
dont de telles proportions sont financés
comment ils vont être financées par la
dette au par l'impôt
c'est tout simple dire par exemple qu'il
faut qu'il ne faut pas reculer l'âge de
la retraite ça me semble difficile
là les retraites aujourd'hui sont
finançables aujourd'hui immédiatement
mais demain on fait comment on va
financer ça comment donc en fait c'est
cette démarche que nous avons que nous
avons voulu que nous avons voulu
entreprendre et dire voilà ce programme
ne semble plus viable qu'un autre
programme mais face à ce programme donc
emmanuel macron avait quand même vous le
soulignez dans le communiqué quelques
lacunes mais il est meilleur à vos yeux
ce programme il est plus réaliste
- difficile pour les finances publiques
plus favorables aux entreprises à
l'économie je dirais vous savez la crise
du coc vide je pense que le emmanuel
macron a su effectivement protéger
l'économie protéger les salariés aussi
c'est cette expérience et sa démarche
qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui est qu'on
souhaite effectivement continuer mais
vous parliez aussi d'un contexte
difficile pour les chefs d'entreprise
j'en profite de vous avoir en plateau
pour parler aussi des conséquences
économiques d'un événement qui est
survenu le 24 février dernier c'est
cette guerre en ukraine avec des
conséquences on le sait sur l'économie
ça a entraîné une flambée des prix voire
des pénuries sur l'énergie on pense
forcément au gaz russe en premier lieu
dans l'autre sens aussi d'aider rupture
de liens économiques et commerciaux avec
la russie est-ce que dans le monde
économique évidement on ressent les
impacts de cette guerre en ukraine tout
à fait vous savez les chefs d'entreprise
sont deux des citoyens comme les hommes
comme les autres nous avons perçu
beaucoup d'émotion comme d'ailleurs
d'autres personnes oui parce que
on n'accepte pas si vous voulez 7 cette
guerre cette agression qui est
contre le peuple ukrainien néanmoins
cette guerre a certainement un impact
d'abord un impact sur l'énergie
l'augmentation des prix l'énergie
engendre des des augmentations de prix
des hausses je dirais très importante
dans nos sur nos sites de production
mais aussi de salariés ont du mal
effectivement à financer l'énergie pour
venir jusqu'au jusqu'au
le travail est à ce titre
nous sommes devant cette difficulté la
biao-ci disons sur l'export d'une
manière macroéconomie qui a pas trop
d'impact mais sur le marché intérieur
français oui la matière première fait
défaut aujourd'hui le nickel le
palladium l'aluminium qui impacte et des
secteurs importants notamment dans les
yvelines l'hérault nautique
l'électronique l'automobile donc il ya
une inquiétude aujourd'hui absolument
absolument une dernière session
j'imagine qu'une vigilance particulière
sur sur ce sujet avec l'élection
présidentielle forcément ça en toile de
fond de ce conflit en ukraine bah
justement si vous voulez
il y a je dirais deux démarches deux
approches encore une fois le côté
économique
nous avons effectivement des inquiétudes
par rapport au programme de marine le
pen qui va nous amener à une certaine
je dirais la france bat isoler la france
peut-être va prendre des positions
assez assez rigide assez draconiennes
alors que de l'autre côté effectivement
l'expérience la démarche
le programme ne laisse dire
qu'effectivement il vaudrait mieux le
programme du monument que le programme
de deux miles and merci zakaria he did
est revenue en plateau je vends mais je
le rappelle vous êtes le président du
medef 78 merci on continue de parler de
l'élection présidentielle le deuxième
tour au programme le 24 avril prochain
toute cette semaine tv 60,18 vous en
apprend plus sur le rôle du président de
la république au coeur de ce scrutin
puisqu'il s'agit de choisir la personne
qui va diriger l'état pendant les cinq
prochaines années un raphaël mata
duvignau du collectif des surligneurs
décrypte ce soir ce qu'est le statut du
président de la république regardez
cette chronique
clé de voûte des institutions de la vème
république le président de la république
est élu au suffrage universel direct
pour cinq ans et ne peut exercer plus de
deux mandats consécutifs
la constitution lui confère un statut
très protecteur pour les actes accomplis
dans l'exercice de ses fonctions il est
totalement irresponsable sur le plan
politique en effet il ne peut être
sanctionné ou renversés légalement par
un autre pouvoir sur le plan judiciaire
de même il ne peut faire l'objet
d'aucune action ou poursuites pénales
toutefois de limites premièrement il
peut être traduit devant la cour pénale
internationale en cas de crimes de
guerre deuxièmement il peut être
destitué par le parlement réuni en haute
cour en cas de manquement à ses devoirs
manifestement incompatible avec
l'exercice de son mandat mais en dehors
de l'exercice de ses fonctions il est
pénalement responsable mais seulement à
l'issue de son mandat en effet la
prescription des faits est suspendu rend
l'exercice des fonctions présentiel et
les poursuites et actions pénales
peuvent reprendre une fois le montage
fait c'est ce qui s'est passé avec
jacques chirac ou nicolas sarkozy par
ailleurs si le délit d'offensé au chef
de l'état a été abrogée ce dernier peut
toujours défendre ses droits en dessous
levant la diffamation l'injure publique
ou l'outragé à une personne dépositaire
de l'autorité publique en cas de décès
de démission de destitution ou
d'empêchement définitif constaté par le
conseil constitutionnel l'intérim est
alors assurée par le président du sénat
qui dispose de la plénitude des pouvoirs
présentiel à l'exception toutefois du
droit de dissoudre l'assemblée nationale
du recours au référendum ou d'initier
une révision constitutionnelle
enfin son statut lui confère des titres
honorifiques comme ceux de grand maître
des ordres nationaux de la légion
d'honneur ou du mérite de coprince
d'andorre deux premiers chanoine de la
basilique de saint jean du latran ou
encore de protecteur de l'académie
française et du domaine national de
chambord son statut donc si particulier
le qualifiant parfois de monarque
républicain est liée à l'étendue de ses
pouvoirs et la suite demain mercredi
avec un focus sur les pouvoirs du
président de la république
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité les récents
épisodes de gel qui entraîne des pertes
considérables pour les agriculteurs
yvelinois la nuit de dimanche à lundi a
été la plus froide la plus froide pour
un mois d'avril depuis
1947 les producteurs s'attendent à
connaître d'autres nuit et je les met
donc en place des solutions pour sauver
leurs récoltes exemple à feucherolles
avec célia 400 go tout ce qu'on voit là
donc on voit bien que pas mal qui ont
cramé
malgré le ciel bleu et le soleil présent
les températures de certaines nuit
d'avril ont été négatives comme celles
de samedi 9 et dimanche 10 avril une
conséquence directe sur les productions
agricoles ici à feucherolles leslie elle
faire cultive des kiwis en bio elle a
planté deux hectares en 2018 et attend
une première récolte fin octobre
l'arboriculteur est inquiète du gel sur
ces cultures trois nuits de gel la
dernière était la plus forte
donc voilà on la met deux premières nous
on avait réussi
les sauver à -2 ça avait tenu moins 3,3
ça tient pas je pense qu'il ya 70% des
bourgeons qui ont joué cette nuit pareil
il est annoncé - un sous abri ce qui
veut dire que quand c'est pas souza
brive c'est au moins deux voire moins
trois des techniques sont donc utilisés
pour réduire les dégâts comme
l'aspersion des jets d'eau qui arrosent
les cultures en continu leslie elle
faire utilise une autre solution elle
fait brûler de la paille tout autour du
verger il faut éviter c'est énorme balle
au paille qui font quatre ou cinq cents
kilos pour faire des histoires de cordon
assez épais tout au long tout autour du
verger dans les parties centrales
qu'on va humidifiés sinon ça brûle
beaucoup trop vite le but c'est quand
même
que ça chauffe environs de 2 ou 3 heures
du matin jusqu'à ce que le soleil
chauffe sur la parcelle on arrive
probablement a gagné 1 un bon degré
stratégique l'état a mis en place le
régime des calamités agricoles
il assure aux exploitants touchés par un
sinistre climatique caractérisé comme
exceptionnel une indemnisation partielle
de leurs pertes ouais j'ai reçu une
compensation financière mais
c'est très bien parce que effectivement
ça permet quand même d'aider d'absorber
quelques coups mais malheureusement ça
remplace pas du tout une récolte si on
est soumis à ce genre de contraintes
année après année
faire du curatif
n'est pas une sera vivable pour personne
nous pourrons l'état ni pour nous donc
va falloir trouver des moyens en amont
de lutter contre tout ça en attendant
des épisodes de ged sont possibles
jusqu'au 15 mai période des saints de
glace
en bref six mois de prison avec sursis
c'est la peine prononcée par le tribunal
judiciaire de versailles contre un
agriculteur d'auffargis l exploitant de
la ferme des quatre étoiles est reconnu
coupable de maltraitance animale entre
2018 et 2019 93 vaches sous-alimentés
dans un état critique lui avait été
retiré il a également interdiction de
détenir un animal ou d'exercer une
fonction en lien avec les animaux
pendant cinq ans l'individu continue de
nier les faits devrait faire appel de
cette décision autre affaire et autre
condamnation du tribunal de versailles
les propriétaires du haras de gaz on
écope de 10 mois de prison avec sursis
pour homicide involontaire le couple
embauché illégalement nicolas que vous
voyez à l'image le jeune palefrenier de
19 ans est mort dans un incendie survenu
en janvier 2010 est prise au piège au
moment du drame il dormait dans une
pièce située à côté d'une cuve de 700
litres de carburant pas d'alarmé
incendié des issues de secours non
indiquées ou obstruée l'eau avait même
été coupée faute d'installations
électriques de secours les propriétaires
ont dix jours pour faire appel
avant de refermer ce journal retour sur
le concert caritatif pour l'ukraine il
était organisée vendredi dernier dans la
chapelle du château de versailles pour
l'occasion trois jeunes réfugiés
ukrainiens ont rejoint l' orchestre de
l'opéra royal 40 2900 euros ont pu être
ainsi reversée à la fondation de france
le reportage de mathilde franco
[Musique]
c'est dans un cadre somptueux à la
chapelle royale du château de versailles
que le département des yvelines a décidé
d'organiser un concert caritatif pour
l'ukraine il ya une tradition de
générosité dans le département des
yvelines
le drame des populations ukrainienne
à proximité c'est presque à nos
frontières
nous incite naturellement très fortement
à comme on dit faire quelque chose et se
conserve ce soir est une des nombreuses
actions que à l'initiative du
département les fonds récoltés ont été
entièrement reversés à la fondation de
france soit une somme de 42 mille 900
euros chacun peut agir faire un concert
réunir des artistes faire s'élever la
musique tout en offrant des dons pour
soutenir les populations qui souffrent
c'est la chose la plus utile la plus
généreuse et la plus solidaire que l'on
puisse faire chacun peut faire un geste
à sa mesure
l'ambassadeur de l'ukraine en france
vadim omeltchenko étaient également
présents au concert lors de sa prise de
parole il a demandé au public de
respecter une minute de silence pour les
ukrainiens victimes de la guerre
[Musique]
l'émotion était très présente ce sont
trois jeunes réfugiés ukrainiens qui ont
ouvert le concert résidant en france
depuis le début de la guerre rien at a
notamment joué un morceau au piano
qu'elle a spécialement créé pour
l'ukraine
je ressens beaucoup de chagrin beaucoup
de douleur peut-être un peu de peur
aussi mais je suis très honoré car c'est
un lieu chargé d'histoire les sentiments
sont très mélangées et partagé d'un côté
une joie ce soir de faire quelque chose
pour l'ukraine aider mais d'autre part
aussi une tristesse parce que notre pays
est en guerre
je suis très ému
la musique de bach que je vais jouer ce
soir je vais travailler avec un ami qui
se trouve aujourd'hui dans une ville
occupée par des russes il ne sait pas ce
qui l'attend donc l'émotion est très
grande
un chanteur franco ukrainien de l'opéra
national de paris a également fait
spécialement le déplacement
ça me touche au plus profond de moi
parce que ma famille est toujours en
ukraine mes amis
sutout dans les régions fortement
touchées par la guerre dans les zones de
combat
donc si je peux faire quelque chose dit
si
c'est pour eu pour d'autres kenyan qui
souffrent aujourd'hui le concert s'est
clôturée par l'interprétation de l'hymne
ukrainien
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité dans un instant nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture présentée par
célia guettent son goût elle vous
emmènera notamment dans la mythique
salle du jeu de paume à versailles tout
juste restauré belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]